c'est depuis le bureau ovale de la
maison blanche que donald trump a
officialisé ce nouveau rapprochement
sous médiation américaine entre israël
et un pays arabe
entouré du secrétaire d'état marque
propre et eau et de ses conseillers le
président des etats-unis a annoncé un
accord de paix entre l'état hébreu et le
soudan nous avons conclu avec le soudan
il voulait passer un accord et c'était
particulièrement bien parce qu'ils sont
essentiellement guerre avec israël
depuis longtemps dans la foulée de cette
annonce donald trump a également affirmé
qu'au mans cinq autres pays arabes
voulaient normaliser leurs relations
avec israël dont l'arabie saoudite
depuis jérusalem le premier ministre
israélien s'est réjouis de l'annoncé de
cet accord et a assuré que la
coopération concernerait de nombreux
domaines
les délégations du vatican et d'israël
se réuniront bientôt pour discuter de la
coopération dans de nombreux domaines
notamment l'agriculture le commerce et
d'autres domaines importants dans nos
citoyens pour obtenir cet accord de paix
avant la présidentielle
l'administration trump a accéléré les
négociations avec le soudan tenant sa
promesse de retirer le pays de la liste
des états soutenant le terrorisme
selon la maison blanche khartoum a en
échange accepté de dédommager les
victimes américaines d' attaques menées
par al qaïda en afrique dans les années
90 une période durant laquelle le chef
de l'organisation djihadiste d'oussama
ben laden avait été hébergé par l'ancien
chef d'état soudanais omar el béchir
il y a plus dans mois les émirats arabes
unis et bahreïn avaient eux aussi
annoncé la normalisation de leurs
relations avec israël lors d'une
cérémonie à la maison blanche
exclu de l'agenda de trump les
palestiniens ont rejeté la signature de
ces trois accords